welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with breaking news about a suspected
chemical weapons attack in Syria it
could be among the deadliest in the
Civil War the reported attack took place
in a rebel health section of Idlib
province in northwestern Syria a warning
video of the aftermath is disturbing
what a but it will be important evidence
as investigators try to confirm whether
chemical weapons were used syrian
activists say at least 58 people were
killed and dozens wounded they blame the
Syrian government or Russian jets Holly
Williams is in Istanbul Turkey Holly
good morning good morning we are still
working to independently confirm whether
this was a chemical attack but the video
is emerging from Syria today certainly
suggests that some kind of chemical
agent was used against civilians
including children we are not airing
some of the most disturbing videos but
this one apparently from the immediate
aftermath appears to show those who were
injured and killed without any visible
wounds those still alive appear to be
having respiratory problems in a clinic
where doctors treat multiple patients in
one video a doctor shows that his
patients pupils are not responding to
light all of that according to a
chemical weapons expert and CBS
contributor is consistent with exposure
to a nerve agent now a blue province is
a stronghold for Syrian rebels and it's
been pounded by Syrian regime and
Russian airstrikes but at this point we
cannot confirm who carried out this
attack in August 2013 a rebel-held area
close to the Syrian capital Damascus
was hit by rockets containing sarin
nerve agent hundreds of people are
thought to have died in that attack the
US and several of its key allies blamed
this Syrian regime gaile all right Holly
those images very tough to see thank you
very much reporting from Istanbul